cómo funciona el voto de moción de
censura y cómo llego boris hasta aquí
hasta la actualidad
buenas tardes es en definitiva la manera
como el partido conservador cambia de su
líder será una votación secreta que se
realizará entre las 6 de la tarde y 8 de
la noche de hoy boris johnson necesita
al menos 180 votos para salvarse y los
diputados conservadores están haciendo
sus cuentas tienen que ser muy
cuidadosos porque otra moción de
confianza no podría realizarse hasta en
un año justamente el primer ministro se
reunirán las próximas horas con los
diputados conservadores
359 son en total especialmente con los
rebeldes para tratar de convencerlos de
que todavía pese al desgaste político la
falta de autoridad que lo rodea él es la
persona correcta para seguir liderando
el país y es que aunque los
conservadores llevan varias semanas
sorteando capoteando la baja popularidad
el primer ministro fue abucheado en
repetidas oportunidades durante las
celebraciones masivas que vivió el país
del jubileo de la reina isabel segunda
lo que no es algo común en este país
pero eso dice mucho de cuál es la
sensación que se vive a nivel nacional
justamente y el primer ministro ha sido
como lo mencionaba y además su esposa
protagonistas de este escándalo del
partido ahora luisa qué pasa si pierde
boris cómo sería el proceso para su
reemplazo
los ministros del gabinete que también
son diputados del partido conservador
aseguran que el primer ministro no tiene
ningún peligro pero bueno eso lo veremos
después de las votaciones si el primer
ministro pierde saldrá del cargo pero no
inmediatamente primero debe ser un
proceso de elección interna dentro del
partido de conservador donde los
diputados que consideren puede liderar
el país se presentarán hasta una fecha
determinada entonces empezarán un tipo
de votaciones internas y posteriormente
hasta que queden dos personas y de ahí
saldrá el primer ministro y sólo
entonces boris johnson se irá de downing
street pero pese aunque boris johnson
sobreviva esta noche no significa
necesariamente que el peligro para él
haya pasado porque aún está pendiente la
investigación interna que está
realizando el parlamento británico para
establecerse y boris johnson mintió
deliberadamente
sobre el escándalo del partido así que
tendremos que examinar más adelante las
votaciones cómo quedan los números
porque aún si waris johnson triunfa
no necesariamente significa que se
mantendrá en el cargo por mucho tiempo
más